chaque semaine nous ouvrons les archives
de notre chaîne pour découvrir
quelques-uns des sujets qui ont marqué
l'actualité locale et même à nationale
bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro 2 ça
s'est passé et nous débutons 17 ans en
arrière en 2001 s'écrouler les tours
jumelles du world trade center à new
york l'attentât faisait quelques deux
mille sept cent cinquante trois victimes
dont 1642 seulement vont aujourd'hui
était formellement identifiés et plus de
6000 blessés chacun se souvient
précisément de ce qu'il était en train
de faire à ce moment et de l'atmosphère
et qui régna les jours qui suivirent
dès le lendemain les minutes de silence
sont multipliées sur les lieux de
travail dans les lieux publics et puis
bien sûr dans les casernes de pompiers
regardez ces images que nous avions
diffusé à l'époque
je vous demande de bien vouloir observer
de silence à la mémoire des victimes des
attentats
aux etats unis et d'avoir une pensée
plus particulière pour les 370 de new
york qui sont morts pendant les
attentats
merci
autre lieu autre moment de recueillement
direction montigny le bretonneux où le
club de baseball partager son émotion
ce week-end le monde sportif a rendu
hommage aux victimes des attentats du 11
septembre
des minutes de silence ont été marqués
comme ici par les footballeurs à
guyancourt où par les joueurs de
baseball particulièrement concernés à
montigny
on se sent concerné évidemment comme
tout le monde et puis en tant que
des joueurs déjà de d'un sport américain
on a des étrangers dans cette équipe on
a un américain qui joue avec nous dans
les équipes adverses
il ya bien souvent des joueurs
américains qui viennent jouer en france
autre forme de soutien à l encours l'on
n'a ouvert un livre de condoléances où
les habitants peuvent marquer leur
solidarité
ce livre est accessible en mairie et
puis vous aviez également découvert sur
notre antenne le 12 septembre 2001 le
témoignage d'une américaine résidant à
saint quentin en yvelines
elle nous expliquer comment elle avait
vécu ce moment loin de chez elle
j'étais à mon bureau je travaille
souvent de chez moi et j'ai eu un coup
de fil d'une amie qui n'est bien il faut
que tu te sentes et à la télévision
parce que quelque chose se passe
important que chez toi
tout de suite dans le premier cinq
minutes j'ai téléphoné mon fils à bord
ce camp et puisque je téléphonais
rapidement je peux te suit la demande
après ça je pouvais plus loin des états
unis et donc après de ne pas croire
après de sentir une certaine sensation
de robots avec le bio lance dans le
monde mais troisième sensation était la
puissance et c'est ça le émotion que je
sors plus l'impuissance parce que je
sais que je peux pas aider les victimes
je suis trop loin je peux pas rentrer
chez moi je peux même pas téléphoné à ma
mère quand vous avez votre fils au
téléphone qu est-ce qui vous admirent
tard elle est utilisé un mot assez
boddaert qui utilisent pas souvent de
bons mois mais elle était extrêmement
ému et les dynamos excuses l'avocat
ritaine demande d'abord de supporteurs
c'est ça qui l'a dit voilà pour ce
témoignage toujours glaçant malgré les
années écoulées du 11 septembre 2001
nous passons au 17 septembre 2012 avec
une actualité politique locale chargée
ce jour là le maire de magny les hameaux
jacquelot lloze annoncé sa démission au
profit de son adjoint aujourd'hui
toujours en poste
l'abbé retrouvions jacquelot lieuse ne
sera plus maire de magny les hameaux à
compter du vendredi 21 septembre celle
annonces qu'il a faites à l'occasion du
repas qui clôturait le forum des
associations il a également présenté
celui qui lui succéderait à la mairie
berthe rouillon maire adjoint au
logement et à la petite enfance
il a la moitié de son âge 36 ans et en
sorte que maintenant copie
je prépare déjà l'avenir et que quand on
peut du contexte politique
donc le local qui sont manier les mots
m'apparaît important que donc la
personne qui va me succéder soit connue
déjà avant
- et non pas dans vos moments direction
de municipales de 2014 je sais qu'il ya
donc au niveau à droite beaucoup
d'appétit pour moi c'est d'abord un
grand honneur
on n'y est pas encore c'est le 28 mai
c'est déjà un grand honneur et puis
je la présente vraiment avec beaucoup de
calme et de sérénité puisque c'est vrai
qu'on a une équipe une équipe municipale
au niveau de la majorité qui est
particulièrement solide particulièrement
investi une passation dans la sérénité
loin du climat qui régnait à magny les
hameaux en 1977 quand jacques le lieu
est entré au conseil municipal comme
maire adjoint à l'époque la ville était
placée sous tutelle
shacknews devient maire en 83 il cède
son fauteuil à la droite entre 89 et 95
avant de le retrouver
quatre mandats dans tout le conseil
municipal devrait entériner le vendredi
28 septembre l'élection de bertrand au
lion jacquelot lieuse demeurera
conseiller municipal il a déjà annoncé
qu'il suivrait de près la campagne des
municipales de 2014 en qualité de
président du comité de soutien
l'enjeu est d'importance conserver la
ville à gauche c'est aussi éviter le
basculement de l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise à droite un double
challenge pour le nouveau jeune
prétendant et c'est ainsi que nous
refermons ce deuxième numéro du ça s'est
passé elle m6 revient la semaine
prochaine pour re découvrir ensemble les
événements qui ont marqué les dernières
années
[Musique]